الناقله الثالثه اليوم الذي يتم احتجازها
او السيطره عليها من قبل الحثيين هي ناقله
نفط اعلن مسؤول عسكري امريكي ان مسلحين
مجهولي الهويه اعترضوا ناقله نفط مرتبطه
بشركه اسرائيليه في خليج عدن بريطانيا
تحذر تلبيب من الكابوس القادم واسبانيا
تعلنها في وجه العبريين اتهامات لا اساس
لها من الصحه وسنرد في الوقت المناسب
الفصل الصائل تؤخر تبادل الاسرى فجاه ما
السبب الجيش العبري يواصل عمليته العسكريه
الصين تطارد مدمره امريكيه في البحر
وتركيا تدخل سوق الاسلحه بمنظومه دفاع
جويه محليه زيلنسكي يعلن التعبئه العامه
والبرلمان الاوكراني يرد كندا والاتحاد
الاوروبي يعلنان دعما ثابتا لكاب انقسام
وتشكيك اوروبي في جدوى معاداه روسيا وهجوم
جوي غير مسبوق على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
المخابرات الامريكيه تعلن نتيجه الحرب في
اوكرانيا والناتو يواجه امرا صعبا لزين
السكي اسبانيا تقول
كلمتها حرب القطاع تغير بوصلتها بعد ان
بدات الهدنه لتصل الى اسبانيا وبعد ان
استدعت الحكومه الاسبانيه السفيره العبريه
في مدريد عقب اتهامات عبريه لرئيس الوزراء
الاسباني بيدروس سانشيز قال وزير الخارجيه
الاسباني خوسي مانويل الباريز ان
الاتهامات التي وجهتها السلطات العبريه
لرئيس الوزراء كاذبه ولا اساس لها من
الصحه وغير مقبوله كما وعد الباريز بتقديم
الرد في الوقت المناسب على مزاعم الدوله
العبريه وفق وكاله ايفي ليبدا الرد من
بلديه برشلونه التي اعلنت قطع علاقاتها مع
تلبيب احتجاجا على الحرب على القطاع
بالعوده الى وضع الهدنه قال رئيس هيئه
الاسرى والمحررين قدور فارس ان الجانب
العبريه لعب بلوائح الاسرى المتفق على
تسليمهم ولم يلتزم بنص الاتفاق مشيرا الى
ان الاتفاق نص على تحرير الاسرى حسب
الاقدميه لكن تلبيب لم تلتزم به لتعلن
الفصائل تاخير اطلاق سراح الدفعه الثانيه
من الاسرى العبريين حتى تلتزم الابي ببنود
اتفاقيه الهدنه الموقعه وفي وقت سابق قالت
القناه 12 العبريه ان م ص را امنيه تقول
ان اسبابا فنيه وراء تاخر بدء عمليه
الافراج عن المحتجزين العبريين من جهته
صرح المساعد السابق للرئيس الامريكي للامن
القومي جون بولتن بان تلبيب سمحت للفصائل
بتحقيق نصر كبير من خلال الموافقه على
صفقه تبادل الاسرى والهدنه الانسانيه لكن
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني الجديد ديفيد
كاميرون حذر تلبيب من انها لن تعيش في
امان ما لم تكن هناك سلامه وامن واستقرار
طويل الامد للفلسطينيين فيما اعلن ضياء
رشوان رئيس الهيئه العامه للاستعلامات ان
مصر تجري محادثات مكثفه مع كل الاطراف
للتوصل الى اتفاق لتمديد الهدنه بين
الجانبين لمده يوم او يومين اضافيين مع
تلقي اشارات ايجابيه من كل الاطراف وفق ما
نقلت رويترز من جهته اعلن رئيس اركان
الجيش العبري هارتس ليفي ان تل ابيب ستعود
الى القصف والمناوره في القطاع بعد انتهاء
الهدنه معتبرا ان الضغط العسكري هو ما
يضمن اعاده كل المختطفين لتعلن الفصائل ان
مقاتليها في جينين يخوضون اشتباكات عنيفه
مع قوات واليه الجيش العبري المتوغلة
ان تلبيب قتلت خلال اقل من شهرين اكثر من
ضعف عدد النساء والاطفال الذين قتلوا في
اوكرانيا خلال عامين من الحرب في بريطانيا
شارك عشرات الالاف من المتظاهرين في
مظاهره دعما للقطاع في العاصمه لندن
وبعيدا عن اجواء الحرب اعلنت شركه اسيلسان
التركيه للاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه انها
ستزود الجيش التركي بمنظومه سيبر للدفاع
الجوي محليه الصنع العام المقبل والتي لها
اهميه كبيره لتلبيه احتياجات الدفاعات
الجويه متعدده المستويات لننتقل الى الصين
حيث اعلن الجيش الصيني طرد م دمره امريكيه
من طراز يو اس اس هوبر دخلت بشكل غير
قانوني المياه الاقليميه الصينيه قباله
جزر شيشه في بحر الصين الجنوبي ونقلت
القناه عن تيان جون لي الضابط الكبير في
القياده القتاليه الجنوبيه لجيش التحرير
الشعبي الصيني قوله ان الجيش الصيني نشر
قواته البحريه والجويه لتعقب و مراقبه
وتحذير
السفينه خطه
زيلينسكي بعد ان افلت الحرب من بين يديه
كما تقول التقارير الغربيه اعلن الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي خطه شامله
جديده للتعبئه في اوكرانيا الاسبوع المقبل
مشيرا الى انها خطوه مهمه على الرغم من
التعقيدات المحيطه بها هناك وصف رئيس لجنه
الامن القومي والدفاع والاستخبارات في
البرلمان الاوكراني رومان كوسينكو عمل
تعبئه الاوكرانيين في الجيش بالفاشل مؤكدا
انها ستتسبب بمشاكل كبيره للسلطات
الاوكرانيه فيما اعتبر النائب ديفيد
اراميا رئيس الكتله البرلمانيه لحزب
زيلينسكي ان موسكو سوف توافق على الفور
على اقتراح كياف الشروع في التفاوض بمجرد
ان توجه كياف لها الدعوه بحسب صحيفه
سترانا من جانبه قال المستشار السابق
لمكتب الرئيس الاوكراني ان تحقيق القوات
الاوكرانيه فوزا على ارض المعركه امر
مستحيل خاصه وان الغرب غير قادر على
تزويدها بالاسلحه لمواجهه روسيا اما
المستشار السابق لرئيس البنتاغون دوغلاس
مكريجر فاوض على حسابه في منصه اكس ان
النزاع الاوكراني استنزف جميع الاحتياطات
العسكريه الامريكيه مضيفا ان زعماء دول
حلف النتو يقفون على الهامش مطالبين
الرئيس الاوكراني بترك منصبه واشار الى ان
الغرب يريد استبدال زيلينسكي بمرشح موثوق
به يمثل ما تبقى من اوكرانيا في ذلك الوقت
لياتي الرد ال من جانب كندا والاتحاد
الاوروبي باعلانه دعمهما الثابت لاوكرانيا
في محاربه روسيا فيما افادت وكاله بلومبرج
نقلا عن مصادرها بان بعض الدول في الاتحاد
الاوروبي تعارض فرض عقوبات جديده ضد روسيا
تطال دولا اخرى في العالم وتشكك في جدوى
مثل هذه العقوبات في فرنسا افاد زعيم حزب
الوطنيين فلوريان فليبو بانه ينبغي على
الغرب ان يدفع الرئيس الاوكراني للتفاوض
مع روسيا مع رفع العقوبات المفروض على
موسكو في اقرب وقت ممكن وعلى الارض قال
ضابط المخابرات الامريكي السابق سكوت ريتر
ان اوكرانيا قد تخسر 50% من اراضيها بعد
انهيار القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بينما
افادت صحيفه تيليغراف بان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه لن تتمكن من وقف التقدم
العسكري الروسي بسبب عدم قدره الدول
الغربيه على تزويد كياف بعدد كاف من قذائف
المدفعيه عيار 155 مليمترا ميدانيا ايضا
قالت السلطات الاكرانيه انها اسقطت 71
مسيره روسيه خلال الصباح وبحسب الاداره
المحليه العسكريه للعاصمه الاوكرانيه فقد
تم سماع اصوات انفجارات عنيفه ما اسفر
ايضا عن اندلاع حرائق عده ووصفت السلطات
الاوكرانيه الهجوم بانه الاعنف من نوعه
على كياف منذ بدء العمليات العسكريه
[موسيقى]
الروسيه
الله
اكبر